der politische patient kremlkritiker
nawal nach vergiftungs verdacht nun in
berlin
corona experiment ein test konzert mit
tausenden probanden in leipzig pandemie
und repression harte strafen für
quarantäne brecher in venezuela
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend kristin otto
und ich heißen sie willkommen bei den 19
uhr nachrichten am samstag sport in etwa
15 mit top fußball gelernt
heute morgen hat ihn ein privat
finanzierter rettungsflug aus sibirien
nach berlin gebracht wer möglicherweise
vergiftete jedenfalls schwer kranke
kremlkritiker alexej nawalny derzeit im
koma wird nun in der charité behandelt
seine frau und enge freunde haben bei
den russischen ärzten darum gekämpft die
ausreise nicht weiter zu verzögern
offenbar hat sich neben bundeskanzlerin
merkel auch der finnische präsident bei
präsident putin dafür eingesetzt david
gebhard um kurz vor 9 in berlin-tegel
hat die odyssee am ende
stundenlang hatten zuvor
familienangehörige des kreml kritikers
im sibirischen omsk um eine ausreise
gerungen nun ist alexej nawalny auf
deutschem boden per eskorte mit
blaulicht und auffällig viel
polizeischutz geleitet in die klinik
charité
wir sind unglaublich erleichtert nicht
nur das mit dem flug den er geordert
doch noch irgendwie geklappt hat mit
hängen würden sondern dass er seinen
zustand während des fluges stabil
geblieben ist dass der flug fehlen nicht
von nachteil war dass wir die große
befürchtung aber machen wir uns nichts
vor erst nach wie vor in einem extrem
kritischen zustand navalny sei noch im
koma gewesen nicht ansprechbar sagen
seine unterstützer die ihnen per privat
finanzierten rettungsflug nach berlin
brachten sie glauben der
oppositionspolitiker sei vorsätzlich
vergiftet worden
russische ärzte sprachen dagegen von
einer stoffwechselstörung
am donnerstag hatte bundeskanzlerin
merkel angeboten navalny in deutschland
zu behandeln und aufklärung gefordert
heute legt der bundespräsident nach es
ist nicht weniger wichtig dass die frage
nach der ursache der dramatischen
verschlechterung
seines gesundheitszustandes ebenso
beantwortet wird und ich hoffe dass alle
diejenigen die zur klärung dieser fragen
etwas beitragen können dies tatsächlich
tun
schärfer formulieren koalitionspolitiker
deutliche worte in richtung kreml
es sieht dem äußeren geschehen nach so
aus als wäre es ein weiterer fall des
versuchten mordes und der botschaft an
die opposition wir kriegen euch in der
charité wird navalny nun untersucht und
behandelt die ergebnisse sind da nicht
nur medizinisch relevant sondern längst
hoch politisch ja ein hochpolitischer
patient nachfrage bei unseren
korrespondenten in berlin zunächst
carsten behrendt vor der charité carsten
weiß man denn schon wann mit ersten
untersuchungsergebnissen zu rechnen ist
die charité hält sich da noch sehr
zurück offiziell bestätigt wurde heute
nur das eintreffen der wein ist hier in
der klinik die ärzte haben um zeit
gebeten
sie wollen erstmal ausgiebig untersuchen
und es könnte bis montag dauern bis sie
sich dann offiziell erklären ich habe
hier heute lange gesprochen mit jaka
bizilj von cinema for peace der diesen
rücktransport organisiert hat er ist mit
der bahn ist ehefrau julia vom flughafen
tegel hier zur klinik gefahren
und er hat mehrfach gesagt dass er den
zustand wirklich für sehr
besorgniserregend hält also große sorge
hier um den zustand und um auch das
überleben von der wahl nie es scheint
jetzt dass diese ankunft hier in berlin
wirklich nur ein weiteres kapitel in
diesem krimi ist aber bei weitem noch
kein happy end
theo koll hallo wir haben gesehen wie
viel polizei den transport des patienten
der wahlen begleitet hat ein zeichen
dafür wie sehr sich deutschland um die
sicherheit dieses mannes sorgt ein
klares ja also formal ist navalny
offensichtlich sogar gast der
bundeskanzlerin das ist aber
ausdrücklich kein politisches signal so
offensichtlich ein bürokratischer kniff
der mitte unter die zuständigkeit des
bundeskriminalamtes fällt und damit dann
auch bestmöglichen polizeischutz erhält
so jedenfalls war die eben erteilte
auskunft des bundesinnenministeriums
offensichtlich geht man im fall von
herrn nav allen die von einer weiterhin
bestehenden gefährdung aus dass
neuwahlen
kein staatliche funktionsträger ist war
bei dieser entscheidung über
polizeischutz offensichtlich auch nicht
ausschlaggebend die bundesregierung hält
sich ansonsten sehr zurück in der
kommentierung aber nicht zuletzt dieser
gewährte polizeischutz kann dann doch
auch als ein politisches signal richtung
moskau gewertet werden dass man
angesichts der vielen vorangegangenen
mordanschläge und der langen russischen
gift spur den dortigen
unschuldsbeteuerung nicht so ganz klar
danke danke carsten nach berlin
angesichts der andauernden
massenproteste in belarus hat machthaber
lukaschenko das militär eingeschworen
bei einem truppenbesuch forderte er die
armee müsse die striktesten maßnahmen
ergreifen um das land zu verteidigen
gestern abend versammelten sich in der
hauptstadt minsk tausende zu einer
kilometerlangen menschenkette
sie erinnerten mit flaggen blumen und
plakaten an die vielen oppositionellen
den noch inhaftiert sind oder verletzt
wurden
und wir schauen auf die korona zahlen in
deutschland sie steigen weiter im
schnitt der vergangenen woche wurden
täglich 1320 neuinfektionen gemeldet
gestern lag die zahl noch bei 1290 das
robert koch institut registrierte heute
2034 neue fälle innerhalb eines tages
der höchste wert seit ende april zum
höhepunkt der pandemie im frühjahr
hatten täglich gemeldeten neuinfektionen
bei mehr als 6000 gelegen
weiterhin viele sorgen machen den
behörden die heimkehrer aus
risikogebieten thomas garcia split heiße
nacht im hotspot abstand maske
fehlanzeige fire fieber trotz der virus
krise als hier getanzt wird gilt schon
die reisewarnung die ansteckungsgefahr
steigt doch immer noch hält sich nicht
jeder an die regeln
wir haben 2 80 jährige dabei
wir halten abstand da kommt ein paar
tische freien wo alle drauf sehen und
gewinn
und wenn man sowas vermeidet dass man
trotzdem mit dran und muss halt auch ein
test machen ungerecht sagen viele und
noch etwas anderes sein ungerecht dass
jeder einen kostenlosen test erhält der
aus einem risikogebiet zurückkommt das
kann auf dauer nicht die allgemeinheit
bezahlen wer in ein risikogebiet reist
muss ähnlich wie die flughafengebühr
auch für seine tests geradestehen testen
am flughafen reicht aber nicht sagt der
deutsche städtetag den vielen reisen
nicht auf dem luftweg gerade aus den
risikogebieten des balkan
deshalb müssen wir unser augenmerk auch
auf die busse auf die bahn und auf das
auto legen
das heißt wir brauchen auch dort mehr
testangebote anflug an bahnhöfen an
busbahnhöfen das muss ausgeweitet werden
allerdings bei ankunft abstrich
eigentlich sei das gar nicht sinnvoll
sagen einige mediziner
lieber solle man ein paar tage in
quarantäne und dann erst testen weil wir
es hat eine gewisse inkubationszeit und
der gerade zum beispiel der letzte abend
oder der der heimflug werden von dem
test direkt am flughafen nicht
abgegriffen und insofern ist eine
verzögerte testung absolut sinnvoll
der kampf die in corona was wirkt am
besten sicher nur vorsichtig sein auch
im urlaub das ist mit abstand die
richtige strategie ein halbes jahr ist
es her dass in hanau ein 43 jähriger
deutscher aus fremdenhass forderte bei
einer kundgebung in der stadt gedachten
etwa 250 menschen darunter freunde und
angehörige der neun opfer
sie werfen den behörden versagen vor sie
hätten warnsignale im vorfeld der tat
nicht ernst genommen
die eigentlich geplante großdemo wurde
von der stadt wegen vieler coroner
neuinfektionen verboten
ein popkonzert tausende drängen sich an
eingängen und in der halle tanzen singen
mit keine gute idee in corona zeiten
großveranstaltungen sind tabu eine
ausnahme heute in der arena leipzig drei
konzerte mit pop star tim bendzko unter
strengen sicherheitsmaßnahmen
namen und im dienste der wissenschaft es
sollen daten gesammelt werden um risiken
bei großveranstaltungen besser
einschätzen zu können
andreas weiße schlange stehen für ein
experiment mehr als 1500 probanden sind
gekommen um an einem test mitzuwirken
der zeigen soll die hallenkrone zeiten
genutzt werden können
für konzerte oder sportveranstaltungen
kleinen beitrag leisten zur pandemie
bekämpfung und im endeffekt aber sind
basketball fans aus dresden und hoffen
natürlich dass jetzt in die halle gehen
zu können
alle hier haben einen sogenannten tracer
um der bewegungsprofile aufzeichnet in
der leipziger arena gibt es dann drei
konzerte szenarien ohne mit etwas und
mit viel abstand so stellen die forscher
der uni halle hygiene konzepte auf den
prüfstand
alle hier sind vorab getestet müssen
aber auch sicherheitshalber so genannte
ffp zwei masken tragen die versprechen
deutlich mehr sicherheit als die
normalen mund nase masten
die forscher erhoffen sich von der
studie dass
wir mit dieser pandemie die wir
beherrschen müssen wo wir auch dafür
sorgen müssen dass nicht leute ernsthaft
daran erkranken aber dass wir mit dieser
pandemie so umgehen können dass
weiterhin ein lebenswertes leben in
diesem land merkel
[Musik]
tim bendzko und seine band spielen auch
mit im wahrsten sinn des wortes aus der
ferne fast ein normales konzert
wir haben im sommer autokino konzerte
überstanden dementsprechend ist das
heute für uns tatsächlich gefühl der
erste schritt richtung normalität
nicht nur in deutschland weltweit werden
die ergebnisse der studie mit spannung
erwartet und sechs wochen sollen die
verkündet werden das corona virus
verschärft besonders dort die lage wo er
schon schlechte lebensbedingungen
herrschen
das zeigt sich besonders in südamerika
alleine brasilien meldet aktuell über
3,5 millionen fälle und möglicherweise
liegen die zahlen auf dem kontinent noch
viel höher
beispiel venezuela nur rund 38.000
offiziell gezählten fälle doch
transparenz fehlanzeige
journalisten können kaum noch frei
berichten über die katastrophale lage
die sich durch corona noch verschlimmert
hat peter theißen gelangen trotzdem ein
einblick
eine frau die hunderte meter weit wasser
in kanistern nach hause schleppt sie hat
noch glück andere stehen stundenlang in
der schlange in der stadt maracaibo wird
kaum noch ein auto benzinmangel
ausgerechnet mitten im zentrum der
venezolanischen ölindustrie ramon
gonzales transportiert wasser mit seinem
eselskarren um irgendwie zu überleben
die leute bezahlen mich mit reis und
mehl
ich muss zu hause vier leute ernähren
und sein enkel carlos sagt manchmal gehe
ohne abendessen ins bett
fast immer fügt sein opa hinzu jeden tag
fällt der strom aus
doch die menschen wissen nie um wie viel
uhr oft sind sie gerade am kochen und
alles geht aus die einwohner makaay bus
werden im wortsinne im dunkeln gelassen
wir haben kein wasser kein strom kein
internet nichts gar nichts
schuld ist eindeutig die regierung die
regierung unter präsident maduro von der
schweren krise offenbar überfordert
lässt sie quarantäne brecher unter
überwachung in der sonne sitzen
venezuela sei das einzige land in dem
eine krone infektion wie ein verbrechen
behandelt werde man die opposition wie
es menschen ergeht die ernsthaft
erkranken das lässt sich bei diesen
bildern aus einem krankenhaus in
maracaibo erahnen
viele kleinkinder in deutschland sind
nicht vollständig geimpft die 13
empfohlenen impfungen darunter masern
tetanus und keuchhusten hat nur knapp
jedes zweite 2017 geborene kind bekommen
nämlich 49 prozent damit hat sich laut
einer studie der techniker krankenkasse
die impfquote im vergleich zum vorjahr
nur leicht verbessert 3,5 prozent der
kleinkinder seien gar nicht immunisiert
worden
allerdings würden manche eltern ihre
kinder zu einem späteren zeitpunkt nach
unten
heute ist ein datum der unangenehmen
sorte 22 august ehrt überlastung tag der
tag also an dem die menschheit alle
nachwachsenden ressourcen verbraucht hat
die unser planet rechnerisch in einem
jahr produzieren kann ab jetzt leben wir
von der substanz der erde
ein nebeneffekt der korona krise wegen
des globalen wirtschaftseinbruchs legt
der tag drei wochen später als im
vorjahr marco berichtet leere straßen
geparkte flugzeuge stehen die
fließbänder im coroner lockdown kamen
viele länder zum stillstand schlecht für
die wirtschaft gut dagegen für umwelt
und natur
der tag im jahr ab dem die menschheit
bei den ressourcen auf pump lebt hat
sich spürbar nach hinten geschoben
die hauptgründe der co2 fußabdruck durch
öl gas und kohle ist nach den
berechnungen des global footprint
networks um 14,5 prozent kleiner
geworden und in der weltweiten
forstwirtschaft gab es einen ruck
um 8,4 prozent umweltschützer allerdings
sehen keinen grund zum jubeln
wir müssen uns auch vor augen halten
dass der ressourcenverbrauch immer noch
beispiellos in der menschheitsgeschichte
ist also 1990 in meinem geburtsjahr war
der erde belastungs tag noch am 17
dezember
und jetzt sind wir am 22 august wenn die
menschen weiter so wirtschaften wie
jetzt bräuchten sie die ressourcen von
1,6 erden so die berechnungen offen ist
natürlich ob sich diese zahl nach dem
komma disaster verbessert oder wieder
verschlechtert ganz offenbar hat ja
menschliches handeln erheblichen
einfluss auf den zustand der erde
allerdings eine ökologische balance darf
natürlich nicht durch desaster erreicht
werden sondern nur durch design gemeint
ist konsequentes nachhaltiges
wirtschaften
die aktuelle krise könnte daher auch
eine chance sein um etwa mit gezielter
wirtschaftshilfe die weichen für die
zukunft neu zu stellen
zum sport und jeder menge fußball
es gab schon die erste jubel arie
gestern abend in köln der fc sevilla
gewinnt bereits zum sechsten mal das
finale der europa league 3 2 gegen inter
mailand vor leeren rängen ein
spektakuläres und sehr emotionales
endspiel sechste europäische titel für
den fc sevilla seit 2006 dieses finale
entschieden durch ein technisches
kabinett stützen und ein eigentor
aber der reihe nach torjäger lukaku mit
der führung für inter strafstoß fünf
minuten gespielt dann trifft dein ex
gladbacher doppelt für silvia luckner
jong in der zwölften und 33 minute
sevilla führt und muss den ausgleich
hinnehmen guten in der 35 2 zu 2 zur
halbzeit in der 65 schlüsselszene dieses
finales lukaku allein für bono
riesenchance vorbei und lukaku
erst in der 74 den fallrückzieher von
costa ab ins eigene tor sowie jubelt
dank luuk de jong
ich arbeite hart mein job ist es zu
treffen ich mache das aber nicht für
mich ich will zusammen mit dem team
pokale gewinnen
hat geklappt die andalusier können
europapokal ja und wer champions league
sieger wird das können sie morgen abend
live hier bei uns im zdf miterleben von
20 uhr 15 an ein spiel der superlative
unterteilt der fc bayern münchen seinen
sechsten triumph in der königsklasse an
seit 29 pflichtspielen unbesiegt soll
nun gegen final neuling paris an sommer
die krönung das zweite triple der
vereinsgeschichte perfekt gemacht werden
den charme ihres portugiesischen
gastgeber ortes haben die bayern profis
allenfalls am rande registriert für sie
zählt derzeit allein das estadio da luz
flick müller kimmig und koffer zwei
stunden vor der abschlusspressekonferenz
für müller bereits das viertelfinale für
kimmig eine premiere die er postwendend
nutzen will die generation vor uns die
hat er ja ein ein anlauf gebraucht um
das dann ja später fix zu machen wir
wollen es direkt im ersten anlauf
schaffen und dafür werden wir morgen
alles geben damit sie dabei nicht
verkrampfen sondern schön locker bleiben
wollen sie die worte ihres trainers
beherzigen und vorfreude entwickeln das
macht einfach spaß gegen die besten sich
beweisen zu können und ja morgen ist ein
besonderes besonderes spiel
torjäger lewandowski stand die vorfreude
sogar schon heute ins gesicht
geschrieben und mehr zum morgigen großen
champions league abend nachher auch im
aktuellen sportstudio von 23 uhr an
die spannung wächst jedenfalls ganz
anderes thema zum schluss öffentliche
toiletten sind normalerweise keine
attraktion
anders in tokio dort stehen jetzt
transparente häuschen in pastellfarben
von draußen kann also jeder erkennen ob
die becken sauber sind wenn man sich
einschließt werden die speziell
beschichteten glaswände undurchsichtig
und danach gilt wieder freie sicht auf
ein freies toll zieht gleich ganz anders
aus so ein häuschen zum wetter das hält
morgen regenschauer aber auch
sonnenschein bereit die details gleich
von ist intern so viel von uns danke für
ihr interesse
marietta slomka und das heute journal um
drei viertel 11
und wir sind morgen wieder für sie da um
7 einen schönen samstagabend wünschen
wird schiss
[Musik]
ein show guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter das hoch auf dem
atlantik das dehnt sich richtung
deutschland aus und bringt hauptsächlich
der mitte trockenes wetter aber sie
sehen hier über der nordsee und ostsee
ziehen ihr regengebiete drüber dort wird
es also nass in der kommenden nacht
schon vom emsland bis zur nordsee
kompakte wolken mit regen dazu
stürmischer südwestwind auch ganz im
süden an den alpen schneit es ansonsten
bleibt es da zwischen trocken mit 17
grad in sachsen anhalt und 12 grad an
den alpen meist liegen die werte
zwischen 13 15 teils 16 grad morgen im
tagesverlauf schauer und gewitter vor
allem im nordwesten deutschlands bis
etwa zu den mittelgebirgen dazu
kräftiger südwestwind ansonsten letzte
tropfen im süden zwischen oder und
oberrhein bleibt es aber größtenteils
trocken und dort zeigt sich am
häufigsten die sonne bei temperaturen
bis 26 grad im osten deutschlands und 20
grad an den alpen sowie an der nordsee
die kommenden tage am montag im norden
schauer sonst ist es trocken 18 bis 24
grad und auch die darauf folgenden tage
sind hauptsächlich im norden mit
schauern verbundenen ansonsten werte
mittwoch bis 28 grad
ein schöner abend